what I wanted to say is that I spent my
career struggling with this question my
last 10 years I said the question that's
below this is your question says can I
do this without intentional talk and
this is why I've moved down to a
question about origins of life about
what I would say is how is it that I can
ascribe information to a molecule
there's a we do it all the time and how
can you build that up and you end in
your description you and you you help
yourself to this word representation no
I don't I want to be clear that my
decision not yeah look I'm doing a
shortcut here okay but the real question
is I want to take the concept of
information that we've taken from a very
simple sense of to information and to
build it up big enough so we can talk
about this notion of reference or
aboutness however you want to call it
and significance or the normativity
feature of it I think you can only do it
by using the Shannon Ian model and
amplifying with the concept of work and
and I think I think it's I think it's
basic I'm not sure we're gonna get I
know it very information plus so no let
me pass let me just walk you on
intention so let me just walk you
through a little piece of it so you get
a sense um I don't have time okay so I'm
not gonna I won't give you the whole
question but the the simple question I
asked is for Shannon information there's
the the original entropy of a signal and
then there's what he calls the message
entropy and if the message entropy is
lower than the original entropy that the
possibilities of signal you have some
law reduction of uncertainty that's his
measure but what he and others have
recognized he doesn't go on to talk
about because in fact to quantify you
don't want to go any further than that
you get lost because how many possible
references could that be you know this
is just sort of might unites to the
ground but as bennett charles bennett
would say all media all information is
physical if a medium has changed its
entropy
there's it's not spontaneous has dropped
in its entropy work had to have been
done it has to be an open system so when
I can say that the loss of entropy of a
signal is about something else
it carries it's about this in its
constraint and that bonus is telling me
about work that is not that signal it is
something else in that signal and that's
how we can use so when I use the
arrangement of chairs in this room to
tell me about something if it's in a low
probability state I know that it says if
they're all turned upside down on their
bottoms for example um I know that
something is work has been done on that
and by virtue of the nature of that
unusual constraint I have some clues as
to what kind of work was there what else
is there besides the stuff and that's
that's the ground of the aboutness it
has to be the ground of the aboutness
it's like I understand when we find
hieroglyphics about which we know
nothing we can tell there's got to be a
decoding right and and and and and if
we're clever enough we'll even find it
as long as we've gotten out samples
right well yeah we've got to find out
the correlate so now yes that's not
enough this is just so Shannon is
telling you what's necessary to have any
information and the next question is
what's necessary to have any aboutness
any reference that's still not the
interpretation story that you're after
but there's a couple of us yeah the
final pieces what do we what do we say
when I've got something that's
represents something to me but it's not
information not useful in the block
broad sense we say that it doesn't help
me reduce any of the work I need to do
my favorite example is a jigsaw puzzle
that's upside down
you have no constraints except the shape
you do a lot more work but if you turn
it up right-side up with a picture you
have more constraint and that means you
do less work but I gained from having
those constraints was that I saved work
and my sense is that the whole story can
be told through that way and once you
begin doing that you've left the story
of intentionality
but you've derived in a physical sense
what's accomplished by intent
now that's my five minute spiel on it
but basically all I'm trying to say is I
think we can do it I don't want I don't
want it to be mysterion like you're
saying and thus will we gradually pull
Alex back the parsha analogy with the
discussion that I think Dan in Jerry
were having yesterday about using terms
using teleological terms let's say in in
evolutionary biology it seems to me that
you're really bothered by the use of
intentional language terms when you when
you say you want to get rid of them in
order to have any explanation
explanation that is based on a physical
doesn't know what is that not know
correct okay but that they bottom out
they bottom out okay fine so didn't we
go through a similar story in
evolutionary biology where we have an
interesting concept there that there is
a concept of things being for certain
certain traits organismal traits are for
something they are teleological
but of course that theology doesn't
apply in any mysterion ism it doesn't
imply any God design things that way and
all that sort of stuff it is the result
of series of physical processes right no
no I got off that train a long time
before it got to the station you just
described that's my problem I already
understand it and partly I understand
from the work of Dan from content and
consciousness and from from Jonathan
Bennett linguistic behavior that meaning
is ultimately teleological and that's my
big problem because once I recognize
that there is no teleology I'm pretty
well committed to the claim that there
is no meaning
[Music]
because there's only blind variation and
environmental filtration and this brings
us back to an issue that we talked about
24 hours ago
heard the question of you know the glass
half empty or half full did Newt did
Darwin make purpose safe for naturalism
or did he expunge it from the natural
ists universe and I think you did the
latter and Dan thinks he did the former
so so I'm correct that there is an
analogy there that that it does go there
is right it does go to a Pristina
teleology so it's similar to discussion
we're having yesterday and since I
accept the eyelets the actual question
it's the actual thing and so I don't
seem to be as bothered by what bothers
you because I actually do accept
teleology I don't think that we did
anything like that
okay well that clarifies things over me
at least except that if we can get
meaning if we can get intention ality to
ground out in your way now that would
circle at this since Robbie RSS of why
we're gonna fail that I give has to do
with that but I'm prepared to and in
fact I will be the first to stand up and
salute when the program achieves and I
think it's important for our for the
philosophy of nationalism in fact it's
one of the most important tenets of yeah
yeah yeah you think they're the same we
thought so that is you know Darwin got
rid of team biology and therefore he got
rid of all intentionality including
aboutness in the way that we require it
so don't you sounds like you know rounds
no no no sorry if we can if we can
provide an alternative account of
intentionality yeah that doesn't involve
teleology then I'll be prepared to buy
it and if we can provide an account if
we can make it if we can if someone can
convince me that I'm just wrong about
the nature of reality that there really
are purposes out there they're just what
Darwin in my view substituted for them
then that one did the reason the reason
a story like Terry's is going to be
crucial here
is because when you know one of the
original naturalistic accounts of
meaning right had this problem the
so-called problem of error right if
something means something you've got to
be able to say under what conditions it
might be it might be used wrong at this
Junction columnist and and and one of
the in the eighties one of the ways one
of the standard ways in which people
tried to solve that to add to solve that
problem of error was in and this is
Alex's problem question begging really
because one of the ways we tried to
solve that air was by so-called Helio
semantics things but referring to the
semantic properties function
consciousness and so so so but that's
also why if Terry if Terry can convince
Alex that a story like is does the trick
right then we don't need teleo semantics
to solve the question begging teleo
semantics to solve the problem of error
so now we've got naturalized meaning now
it doesn't matter how we now now the
question about how to read Darwin really
is just a question of what to say right
because then you can look at Darwin from
upside down and look at Darwin
right-side up it doesn't matter anymore
right and and that's and and and and
we've brought Alex back from the cliff
you're scared because you're gonna fall
or you're scared because you're gonna
jump I think Alex jumped in his last
book but so but I actually am getting a
little confused by some of this now too
like Rebecca will but so what's wrong
with saying back to the what's real Oh
humans have purposes for example I mean
psychological purposes so it's a
perfectly legitimate psychological
phenomenon what's up you can't say that
unless you prepared to give a account of
how humans represent that bottoms out
you know a non attention okay I'm going
more simple way than you oh I'm just
saying it's part of the manifest image
if that humans have fur preserves like
Emma's have values and people humans
have intentions not semantics once and
then and we use language to represent
and language has meaning these just seem
like the phenomena that one ought not to
eliminate and I get puzzled by when you
say things like that
the I mean you you sometimes sounds like
you the fact that person Quine didn't
give us a satisfactory theory of
naturalistic meaning I mean first of all
they didn't have neuroscience and if
what but you know it it seems that you
still want us to eliminate or reduce
intentionality whereas the jackendoff
project it was to explain it and that
seems very different to me am i still
wrong others it just seems to me that
the legs our nation is fine with me
provide the explanation doesn't beg the
question by invoking intentional notions
take any homunculus it doesn't put any
undischarged yes right but your are you
willing to wait and see now follow
Rebecca's idea that we're early in this
and I think that you're that you do not
do quite sufficient credit by suggesting
that it was his or everyone's ignorance
of neuroscience back then that led him
to the doctrine of radical
interpretation
I think we're just gonna leave the non
philosophers behind here I'm sorry
indeterminacy of radical interpretation
yes hmm I didn't think twice before so
yeah it's the shorthand for answering
Owen so there's this there's quite has
this wonderful well you're gonna the
student if sorry let me add one more
thing just to give the historical
picture right quick
I'm not gonna say of anything about the
in determines you know the the the the
the a really important book that nobody
read in the late eighties right which
exactly made the point about how you
need the Italian you need a Terry type
story you need to to rescue T leo
semantics from being questioned begging
was Dan Lloyd's book Simple Minds I
think I had second thoughts about trying
to characterize well it might be
possible to do it dead simple first let
me compare two views and you can see if
you can see the difference my view with
photos voter says if you want to know
whether something is a believer look at
its head and see whether or not it's
mentals its brain states represent
beliefs if you want it there no the
question is you know is this a believer
is that a believer is he a believer am i
right we're the believers here he says
look in the head and see if the states
of the brain represent beliefs if yes
you got a believer if no no I say just
the opposite in a certain way I say if
you want to know whether states in the
brain represent beliefs beliefs see
whether or not they are in the head of a
believer and that's you have to see what
a believer is in order to understand how
the states in that brain can represent
things like the shopping list and so
forth and so that the
concept of the intentional system is
prior to the concept of the belief
because beliefs are states of intention
is elaborated and taken over by Jerry
who thinks it's his own is that there is
no unique sentence that can be
attributed to the belief state of the
believer no matter how much we know
about the believers that's not right
quite you is that we could have two
theorists two observers who take dawn
they study up left right and sideways
they both consider him an intentional
system they both consider his brain to
have states that they can interpret his
beliefs however there's always a
theoretical possibility that they might
arrive at different Rosetta stones for
his brain they might arrive at different
catalogues of beliefs for Dawn's brain
and in the limit there would be no
question about whether being right and
one of them being wrong
there simply would be no fact of the
matter and the important thing direct
it's not an epistemic point the
important thing to remember about this
is that he's not saying this is a
practical problem he's saying it's an
in-principle possibility in the actual
world we don't have to worry about this
because a word as it's Terry likes the
constraints are so overwhelmingly large
that the chances of two observers ever
coming up with significantly different
translation manuals for his brain states
is essentially zero finest of grain that
we need for interacting with one another
does not require us to in situate
beliefs down to unique propositions yeah
right but that is a point about
practicalities of life
you